foreign
well well yeah you didn't notice that I
didn't notice them until right now
they're just like yeah there's like a
little square like right in front of
right in front of the spot I'm sorry
spot
mirror Spock yeah he's gonna kick your
ass yeah he's gonna [__] ask for my
agonizer yeah your agonizer please
oh [__] I didn't turn the [__] thing
on either man you just got all kind of
problems I know yeah he's so
disorganized yeah he said your agonizer
Mr Ross thank you
yeah
I need one of those
and anytime you say some [__] up [__]
I can just go
the [__] the Terran Empire was they were
the [__] they made you carry your own
agonizer around like that's like
carrying around your own switch Yeah
yeah that's how they roll man yeah that
works yeah
what's up Tammy what's up everybody
that's out there it's Monday once again
and we're talking about a haunting now
right before we started the show Tom was
like I hope that I remember this [__]
when you start talking about it because
yeah I don't remember anything about it
well he doesn't remember anything about
it I remember we watched it yeah it just
kind of Drew they're all starting to get
kind of the same well you know the the
stories of them are like very similar
one thing I did notice because this
episode is the first episode of season
six because we actually finished season
five last week
um is that
I think I started to notice this in
season five where like I said they were
trying to go like more cinematic like
where they would do like flash forwards
and stuff like they're still doing it
now in season six but one thing I did
notice is that there's less
um there there there's less like
substance because it seems like there's
a lot more
um like you know when there would be uh
a gap like when they would go to
commercial or whatever
um and then it would come back and then
they would spend like a few minutes like
reiterating [__] that they did like
before the commercial yeah so a lot of
it's like repeated because I noticed
like you know when I take notes and
usually the older episodes like I'll
have like three or four pages of notes
and this one I just had too
because not as much happened and so you
know it was like repeated and so I
didn't like write it down again yeah
they're patting them out that's what I'm
saying they're just kind of like
repeating a lot of the information which
you know I guess that's just what they
did maybe it was cheaper they're just
like we're using all the same footage
again well the stories weren't that it
probably wasn't much to the the story to
begin with so then they had to kind of
Pat it out and stretch it out and make
it make it fit it's an hour I think it's
an hour long program so yeah yeah
they're like 48 minutes or something
like it's probably something that could
be told in 15 minutes instead of trying
to stretch it out yeah making it like a
movie yeah that's definitely what they
were doing yeah much like I said that's
you know fair enough that's less for
less for me to write down that's the
series and that whenever the ones end
with an exorcism
in a way that's kind of good because I
don't ever have to write any of that
stuff down because all the exorcisms are
like the same and I'm just like oh
standard exorcism
yeah with everybody like throwing holy
water around and all that kind of jazz
so yeah this one ended with that too
because this one is kind of like did
they say that this was demonic I'm
guessing they implied this wisdom oh
yeah if there's this there's an exorcism
they're gonna say demonic yeah
and that that demonologist uh that
considine fella was on here too
yeah he's on a lot of he's on a lot
what's funny is that it's starting to
blend in with all the other ones I can't
remember how The Story Goes you're gonna
have to start as soon as you start
talking about it I'll remember it
like I said this one's called marked by
evil yeah and I was like did we do that
one already and then like I looked I was
like no we did one that was called
stalked by evil yeah uh which I think
was season four but this is marked by
evil so it's different and in this one
technically you this one probably could
be stalked by evil as well because it is
like a stalker and that's how she gets
the demon that's right I remember it now
that was to do the castle love speller
yeah yeah okay I remember now except
well he said it was a love spell but
instead it was like no really I'm gonna
like torment you with the demons belt is
what it was because he was a he was an
[__] because she didn't like him
so there was that
um but yeah do we have anything we need
to cover before we get into this no
let's go ahead and get into it you get
into it so you'll remember it better
yeah yeah I'm I'm starting to put it
together now I remember the guy who's
pulled her hair out and [__] so he could
make his spell on her
can you imagine moves on her she's like
hey I'm not really I'm not into you and
she was married you know yeah too yeah I
remember that she's like yeah get the
[__] off I'm just kind of like a satanic
witch or we are a satanic warlock or
whatever whatever yeah we'll get into
that a little bit Yeah so uh so this
takes place in Fall of 2008 in Manassas
Virginia or as I like to call it man
asses Virginia I mean you could
pronounce it like that if you wanted to
and I want to so that's what I'm going
to do man asses Virginia
so the woman at the center of this
is a woman named Stephanie winter
now at the very beginning she goes to a
party at her friend's house
and she sees I guess she's never been to
the apartment before but she like sees a
bunch of occult books and that kind of
you know he's got a bunch of goth
paraphernalia I guess in there and I
kind of laughed because they made it
seem it was so very satanic Panic where
he's just kind of like oh he had all
these occult books like the Necronomicon
that was like they they talk about that
like it's like a real like a real book
thing like a real like you know
obviously it's a real book but it's not
like a real old like grimoire or
anything like that it's like just
[__] it's a fake book based on what
HP Lovecraft was talking about right
that's all it is it's not right it's not
old they're nothing Lovecraft made the
necronomiconda yeah it's just part of
his [__] Mythos yeah so that's why I
think it's funny like every time they
talk about that like it's this ancient
Tome that like that people like oh yes
an economico yes the ones that the
ancient Egyptians wrote
yeah and I was like you got this at
Barnes and Noble then
he wrote that one
yeah and all the Shag offs yeah I mean
it's so it's just old ones it's very
silly yeah and I thought like even when
this came out because I think season six
was what 2013. it's by by the time 2013
it rolled around I'm pretty sure
everybody was like pretty clued in to
what the deal with the Necronomicon was
yeah so it's like that's not gonna
impress anybody except like some real
Rubes yeah that like actually think
that's a real thing I can't remember the
only time I think the last time I
remembered somebody being confused about
the existence of the necronomic I was
high school
yeah like that's the that's the last
time Stoners in high school man who are
like in the [__] Black Sabbath and
[__] yeah man an economicon dude yeah
that's some wild [__] it's so that's it
yeah Ozzy Osbourne read it yeah and then
summoned this [__] yeah yeah yeah
I bought it late yeah I bought the
paperback at like the [__] at Walden
books or some [__] for like six dollars
yeah so
murder Hornet said the malleus
I don't know yeah but that's a real book
though yeah that's a real witch hunting
book like you got something that wasn't
made up 1500s I think something I don't
remember when it first it was a
reference book at my High School uh
Library yeah go on there and look at it
it had good wood cuts and [__] yeah and
I have a copy of it something yeah you
could still understand it
you know uh the English was [__]
archaic but it wasn't Old English it was
Modern English just real old yeah you
can understand most of it
um about [__] up witches yeah how to
find witches and how to [__] them up
how to how
you should drown them and [__] like that
you know pictures the woodcuts of them
pressing people like they didn't have
anything better to do back then it's
like we're just gonna go from town to
town and pick up all these [__]
innocent women the names of certain
demons and yeah woodcuts are what they
look like if I remember correctly yeah I
think that was in there like I said I
have a I have a copy of it someplace but
I don't know where it is it's around
here they had a little dictionary of
them
so imaginative they were so imaginative
yeah or encyclopedia they had a whole
Encyclopedia of demons major demons in
there
they've pulled this [__] out of their
ass of course where else is it gonna go
bro it's not real no you can make a lot
of money back in those days just
printing a wild ass book you know the
nobility believed in all that stuff so
if you could just cook up a good story
sell a lot of copies and uh books was
expensive back then that was like more
expensive than buying a laptop
yeah man look I got I got four books you
got four books God damn your library is
[__] fast
four yeah and these are like five years
you're supposed to have these because
it's all about demons yeah
and you know in that era if it was if
somebody took the time to write it down
then it's [__] true
they took that [__] yeah because why
would anybody just make that stuff yeah
yeah little did it little did they know
especially all that [__] about [__]
Alchemy
they were [__] convinced that that
[__] was true
they really were like there was so much
time that they devoted to that yeah and
like even like really even smart people
and [__] like that were like all into
Alchemy well it's funny it had like a
method
to do all this [__]
but it wasn't really science because
they they had already found the
conclusion the Sorcerer's Stone it's
like it's like and making gold yeah and
it they claimed that they could do it
well why weren't they doing it did they
you know they would say just keep
working at it you know I mean the
instructions would just say keep working
on it if you're pure enough and hard
it'll eventually become gold so in other
words it's not really what you did it
was just how pure your heart was
yeah so then they always had an out like
so if you couldn't do it like it's like
well you must be too too simple yeah
you're sorry yeah it doesn't work for
you yeah I'm telling you right now if I
actually figured out a way to turn lead
into gold I wouldn't tell nobody about
that [__] right I would just make a
bunch of gold and retire you're right it
wasn't it wasn't uh chemistry
chemistry kind of came from it but it
wasn't chemistry it was
it was religion it was it was like the
Scientology of the day
but what's funny is that you know Isaac
Newton who's brilliant believed it
yeah I read a whole book about that like
um all the [__] that he was sent to was
it's fascinating like you can see how it
wasn't as weird back then because they
didn't really know
um you know it's not like nowadays where
everybody knows that that's not real but
it's like back then it sounded like well
maybe so you know transmutation of metal
right yeah like it sounded cool and
scientific and stuff so yeah and it had
symbols and [__] yeah and so every
everybody knows that yeah if you have
like some symbols the symbols and
beakers and sure some kind of a method
slightly
that oh it must work no it's made up
yeah well
close not even no it wasn't close the
concept was the had a vague concept of
chemistry but not really now
it was just wishful thinking yeah they
had no no no no no understanding of the
molecular nature of matter they didn't
understand molecules in atoms were
yeah so uh yeah so we got off on the
tangent because of the necronomica
Necronomicon not real like I said it's
it's a real book it's just not
uh it's not old is is what it is so uh
so this was one of the occult books that
he that he had in there and I thought
that was funny that they picked that one
out like the one that's fake
so uh the guy his name's Peter I got
confused because when I was watching the
episode I thought they said she goes to
her friend Steven's apartment for a
party but then the guy that was stalking
her was named Peter and he was the one
that was into the occult [__] so I was
like is he Steven's roommate or did they
just say the name wrong because I called
him Steven for the whole thing and then
like later on they said no his name's
Peter and I'm just like what the [__]
okay I don't know I wasn't paying
attention maybe but uh I'm just gonna
call him Peter so yeah so Peter is
apparently really really into Stephanie
like in a stalkery kind of fashion and
she is really really not into him
they're friends and stuff but um you
know he's like wanting more out of it
and she's like yeah no I don't like you
that way and plus she was she's married
too she got him friends friend zoned he
didn't like yeah I guess not yeah so uh
so at this party he tries to get a
little bit rapey get a little bit handy
um you know and she's just like bro like
get the [__] off you know what I mean
and um you know she's like I don't like
you like that I'm married like piss off
or whatever and then he pulls her hair
out like not all of it obviously but
just like a little handful which
man you're getting punched if you did
that to me but um he's like she's like
the [__] you do that for and he's like
it's for a love spell and she's like
what the [__] ever okay
so Stephanie and her husband who I think
his name was Nicholas or Nick
so they've only been married a year and
I guess they just moved house so they
just moved into this new house now I
guess she's a bartender so she works at
night and he's in construction so he's
usually gone during the day now she gets
home from the party and like she doesn't
tell him about the situation with Peter
which I was like I think I'd be telling
you about that but I don't know maybe I
wouldn't because then you're like I'm
gonna go kill the [__] you know
what I mean because that's probably what
you would do oh me now yeah
stab him around a little bit yes I would
just slap him around a little bit Yeah
Yeah
but she doesn't tell him about it she's
like uh you know the party wasn't that
fun I probably should have just stayed
home or whatever
so then the next morning after hubs goes
to work there's a knock at the door at 5
[__] 30 in the morning like she's
awake I guess because you know she she
just got home from work and it's [__]
Peter knocking on your door at 5 30 in
the morning with a big thing of roses
creepy so yeah
um yeah I guess he was on his way to
work and he's like yeah I just thought I
would like bring these she's like what
the [__] it's like would you just [__]
off like she didn't say that on the show
but it was like that's what she meant
she was just like get the [__] out my
face
um and then basically he's like you
don't want to say no to me and I was
like that's where you're wrong I
absolutely do want to say no to you so
get the [__] off my porch before I call
the cops
um so yeah dude's a [__] stalker
so a few weeks go by and he actually
does stay away like she doesn't see him
for a while she was like phew okay
that's over but probably not
so then the first weird thing that
happens it's like her and her husband
are sleeping it's the middle of the
night
and they hear like this crash like a
bunch of [__] breaking like in the house
like in the kitchen
and so first thing you think which is
what you would think is that there's an
intruder so Nicholas goes out there he's
got like a baseball bat or whatever and
he looks all around the house looks all
around outside and so like obviously
there's nobody there what ended up
happening was I guess all the dishes had
been like in one of those the dish
drainer thing that like sits on the
counter and I guess it like jumped off
the counter and all the dishes were
broken like on the kitchen floor
so of course they're just like well you
know maybe it was just too close to the
edge and it just like you know maybe a
truck went by and like it [__] bumped
it off or something like that like they
didn't really they thought it was weird
but not like super weird so yeah so all
the dishes are broken
um also they did like a really cheesy
jump scare right here which is another
thing that they started doing a lot like
in season five but they really did it a
lot in this one and it's like every
single time they do like this like
Stephanie is in the kitchen or whatever
and then like they'd show like the POV
shot of like the camera like Jason
Voorhees like coming up behind her and
stuff and I'm just like this is her
husband it's her husband and then it's
like oh oh my God you know what I mean
it's like I'm like would you please stop
doing that I hate that it's like so
cheesy but it's like yeah so pretty much
every time it was her [__] husband
like coming up and being like oh sorry I
scared you hon you know it was like that
so uh yeah so a few weeks later
Nick is in the house and I guess he has
a side gig
um like drawing uh tattoos like for his
friends and stuff because I guess he's
like a tattoo artist like on the side
and while he was sitting in the study or
whatever drawing he said that there was
a Candlestick and it basically like flew
across the room
and hit the wall and like left like took
a little chunk out of the wall now he
said I mean from what how he described
it he said he didn't I guess he didn't
see it leave because it was like kind of
out of his like in his peripheral vision
but it was like a big Candlestick and he
just like saw it Fly and like hit the
wall
so at this point they're like okay well
obviously that's paranormal because
there's not really any other explanation
for that like flying across the [__]
[__] like that so like okay well it's
got to be a ghost right
so a couple nights after that Stephanie
wakes up in the middle of the night and
she has like a pain in her back like a
horrible stinging pain and she's like
screaming and flipping out about it and
so he like looks at her back and he's
like oh [__] you don't want to see this
he said that he could see blood forming
on her back like this like you know the
Telltale demonic claw marks on there
like three of them yeah and he said that
he could see the blood just like like
coming out of the cuts what's weird is
that that Poltergeist thing that I saw
it made those scratches in the wall that
was three
when it pulled the damn chain that was
locked that that chained the door shut
and the inside
maybe it's because three is the minimum
amount to give you the the impression of
a claw yeah so it's just like
to expand whatever kind of kinetic
energy it is you need at least three
four might be a waste of time three is
good enough you know it's a claw Mark
yeah it's like that's just enough to
yeah suggest it too you might not know
what that was
weird but I saw it
it's weird
Julian Pope said it was broad daylight
when she answered the door at 5 30 a.m
yeah I noticed that I was like that's
clearly like seven or eight in the
morning because look I get up for work
at five in the morning and it's dark
even in the summer time I wake up with
her half the time
well you do this morning this morning
what time is it it's five o'clock I said
it's five o'clock I'm getting up I'm not
happy about it but I'm getting up our
lady rolled around for about a half hour
well I actually woke up at 3 30 yeah
because I have like terrible uh cotton
mouth like my mouth gets really dry and
so 3 30 the more like my throat had
dried up so much that I started coughing
and that woke me up and then I had to
pee and then I was like so I got up and
then I got back in bed and I said oh I
maybe I can sleep for another hour and a
half yeah no I'm gonna look into that
dry mouth thing maybe maybe you need
some HCG
maybe get your glands running yeah I
don't know what the problem is yeah I'm
just like I'm always like thirsty and my
breath is always dry
well [__] bees nest let me get some of
that HCG from you
I'm gonna [__] bagger up with some of
that
and then murder Hornet also had said I'd
slap a [__] waking me up at 5 30. yeah
so would I I mean like I said I wake up
for work at five but on the weekends if
somebody wakes me up at 5 30 oh yeah I'm
absolutely gonna slap you I don't like
that I don't like it well I don't like
being woke up
I gotta wake up early all week I don't
really like being woke up you know what
I mean I get really really cranky
really cranky
um yeah let's see okay so where was I
all right so fly the Candlestick yeah so
then she has like the claw marks on her
back and everything
so at this point I guess this had been
going on for a while because they said
at this point it's now February 2009 so
I guess they said like a year had gone
by
um since
she well okay here's the weird thing
they said it's February 2009 A year had
gone by since I presume she had told
that Peter guy to go [__] himself but I
thought they said at the beginning that
it was fall of 2008 which um I don't
know if you're calculating but that's
not a year that's only a few months all
right so I don't know what they're
talking about
maybe they've been a year since
something else I don't really know I try
I usually write [__] down but it's like
I don't I just wrote down they said oh
you're gone by I'm like sense when I
don't know
um oh yeah I forgot to mention too that
uh when she had like the claw marks on
her back or whatever
she said that you know she's like I had
a shirt on I had the blanket on it's
like there was no tears in the shirt
there was no you know the blanket wasn't
[__] up or anything like that so she
didn't really know how it happened
now a few days after this this act this
part actually kind of cracks me up a
little bit it was a few days after that
um a friend visits I don't even think
they said what the friend's name was and
they'd never mentioned her again
and she brings a lady from her church
who's supposed to be like a sensitive or
a psychic or something and this part is
great because the friend comes in it's
like hey how are you like I haven't seen
you in a long time and everything and
then like this old battle ax that she
brings with her like this psychic lady
she doesn't even she's like totally
um like doesn't even say hey how are you
or anything like that she just walks in
the house like all
smug like sensing things you know what I
mean I'm just like hi have you been
helped um I didn't she didn't like tell
her to come in or anything she just
wants Waltz right in and started like
sensing [__] around the house and I'm
like rude okay
so uh so yeah
now she comes up with this story that
back in the day it I thought from the
way that the clothing was of you know
the actors in the reenactment and stuff
I thought they were trying to say it was
maybe like Civil War era but I'm not
entirely sure
but the psychic came up with this story
it's like oh there was a family that
used to live in this house or on this
land or whatever the hell
and that the husband was like real
abusive and [__] and then
um he ended up killing his wife and kids
and now he's like haunting the place
still and I was like okay fair enough
um Stephanie at that point notices too
that the scratches on her back have not
healed even though it's been several
days like they still look the same
now Stephanie also said that around this
time she saw a ghost herself like an
apparition that looked like a little boy
she said she only saw him for a few
seconds but she saw him very very
clearly and that he his face was like
really sad so she's maybe presuming that
this is one of the kids of the family
that the psychic said was murdered in
there but like I said they don't you
know nobody checked that so I don't
really know if anything like that really
happened
so then
um a little while later Stephanie is in
the kitchen like cooking or baking or
whatever and scratches like
spontaneously appear on her arm like
really deep ones and again it's three of
them
and she like wigs out about that and at
this point her and Nicholas are like we
really didn't want to tell anybody
about this because we thought everybody
would think we were nuts and so you know
we just didn't want to say anything
about it
and then one night not too much later a
friend of theirs had come over to the
house so that Nicholas could give her a
tattoo because like I said he was kind
of like a tattoo artist on the side
and so it was the girl there and there
was this other chick there who I'm
assuming was her friend or whatever and
while Stephanie was there kind of like
watching what was going on
um she had like scratches in her legs
she said like spontaneously like opened
up you know what I mean everybody saw it
and because everybody saw it they were
like yeah we're out like everybody just
like flipped out and ran the [__] out of
there because they were freaked out by
it
so um so yeah so they just like got the
[__] out
and at this point Nicholas is getting
like really mad and he's just like
challenging The Entity or whatever it is
like asking why he was doing this why
why are you doing this to my wife and
blah blah
and then they jump ahead to November of
2009 so this is kind of like a long term
I think it's like a two-year span of
like [__] that's going on
and the husband says Nicholas he says
she would get scratched like pretty much
all the time he's like it got to a point
where it had happened like half a dozen
times or more like at least once a week
sometimes twice it was just happening
all the time
um you know what I mean so finally
they're like we really were reluctant to
tell anybody about this but finally we
decided we have to do something about it
so they called like a Paranormal
Investigator and this guy's name is Rick
I think it was atcherstein atcherstein I
think is what they said his last name
was like I wrote it down but I'm not
sure if that's how you pronounce it or
not
and he is like a specialist in violent
hauntings I guess
and he says predictably that because
everything is three scratches then
obviously that's demonic
um
yeah yeah sure well they always say
isn't what they always say it's like oh
it's a mockery of the Trinity that's
what they always say like like they
don't know but I'm just saying that's
usually that's that's the going Theory
anyway the hypothesis
so he says well
if you have like some kind of demon you
know [__] with you then obviously
either you invited it and I'm like way
to blame the victim or it was summoned
somehow and so he's like you know he's
like not saying it was you I'm just
saying do you know anybody that was into
the occult or anything like that she was
like oh matter of fact there was this
chode that was like [__] stalking me
and he said he was gonna do a love spell
and pull my hair out and yada yada
so Rick says oh well that dude probably
put a curse on you and that's likely
what's happening at the moment
so he's like um I can come back next
week and do an investigation
um but you know in the meantime
Stephanie is still getting like
scratched and you know senses the entity
and all that other kind of stuff and
like starts yelling at it to get the
[__] out and you know just kind of
screams at it tells Nick it's like we
you know we have to fight it and you
gotta help me fight it blah blah now at
this point Nicholas is like I really
wanted to move like because they haven't
lived in this house that long but Rick
tells them it's like you know don't
bother because this thing is like
attached to your wife and it's like it
would probably just follow you so
there's really not any point
so Rick comes in there and he sets up
all the equipment around the house like
they do and he actually didn't get Jack
which I thought was kind of good that he
actually admitted that it's like we
didn't get anything like on video or
audio or nothing it's like absolutely
nothing happened like when they set it
up so I was like well okay
I'm glad that he didn't just like make
some [__] up or try to be like orbs or
some [__] like that he said they didn't
get anything
um and what Stephanie and Nicholas said
it's like yeah whenever Rick the
Paranormal Investigator was there like
whenever he was there like nothing would
happen but it's like as soon as he left
like Stephanie would start getting
attacked and like shot and like you know
cut up and everything like that
and at this point Stephanie was like so
depressed that she wouldn't even like go
anywhere she's like because I was always
covered with bandages and she's like and
I felt like people were looking at me
and she was like and it was just like
[__] Relentless all the time and so
she just never wanted to go anyplace you
know what I mean so she just like never
wanted to leave the house
so then there was an incident
where Stephanie was in the room like in
the bedroom and she got like forcibly
like pushed down on the bed like and the
thing was like they did a thing where
she was like laying there with her arms
out like that and then they almost did
like a little bit of an impression of
like a person like the entity like yeah
kind of like that it was kind of like
that because there's a movie called The
anody that was like this yeah we talked
that we talked about that like on our
very first episode like many many years
ago yeah
and I think we've done a show about that
case also if I'm not mistaken
but that's that's an interesting case
too I'm not really sure I believe that
lady but it's pretty weird anyway
um but yeah so she's like pressed down
on the bed she can't move or breathe or
anything like that Nicholas is like
flipping out it's like she looked like
she was dying because like she couldn't
breathe or anything and so he starts
like yelling at the ghost so you know
cut why don't you come [__] with me
instead of her and yada yada you know
all the stuff that like dudes say
so then they tell Rick about this
situation and they're like now we're
really worried about it because it's
like it could have killed her and uh you
know so they're like we need to do
something about it
so Rick calls a demonologist for advice
so the demonologist says well what you
need to do is you need to get some
beeswax candles got to be beeswax
candles can't be like those [__]
cheap ass like other ones gotta get some
pontifical incense he said pontifical
incense I'm pretty sure so that's like
some special you can't just go to the
head shop and get incense you got to get
the good [__] uh and also holy water so
they're gonna do like a ceiling ritual
so
um Rick advises that they do this ritual
every night
so they do it so basically so Stephanie
and Nicholas are like this must have got
really tedious after a while it's just
like you had to go like in every room
every single night with your candles and
your I mean how much did they spend on
beeswax candles and I don't know how
much pontifical insets cost but it can't
be that cheap surely so they're just
kind of like going from room to room
saying the prayers and yada yada like
everything like that so they did that
every night apparently for months and
months and evidently at first it worked
like nothing happened for like a really
long time so like nothing happened for
such a long time that Stephanie was
starting to get really relieved it's
like oh man like everything's going back
to normal like we can get back to our
normal life you know and everything's
gonna be good now
now at this point like I said it's been
a while so they did this every night for
a really long time and now it's March of
2011. so like I said it's more than a
year has gone by like since all of this
nonsense started
um and they started and they were doing
the nightly ritual for a year and during
that year apparently nothing happened so
everything was copacetic
one night just suddenly in the spring of
2011 uh Stephanie is in the kitchen and
sees a dude outside the kitchen window
the implication being that it was like
the the ghosty that they saw from before
which was supposedly like the murder dad
you know what I mean that killed this
whole family yeah
um that's it was the same actor anyway I
don't really know if she saw that or
recognized him or anything because I
don't think she ever saw the murder dad
either she said she saw a ghost of a
little boy but I think she said that was
the only entity that she saw
but yeah so the dudes outside the window
so they thought it was a person so like
Nicholas goes out to check but obviously
there's nobody out there
and then when he comes back in and they
did another fake out jump scare right
here and I was like God damn it will you
please stop doing that like I said they
did it like three or four times and it's
like every time I'm like it gets her
husband okay we know it's her husband
just stop it
so he comes back in and then Stephanie
apparently gets yanked down to the floor
like by her hair like something grabs
her by the hair and like pulls her down
like onto her back or whatever
so at this point Nicholas calls Rick
back and says hey you know the attacks
have started back again so what the [__]
do we do
so Rick comes back and he's like okay
what we need to do is we need to do this
48-hour immersion thing where we're
gonna try and get all this evidence
because I need to go to the Catholic
church and ask them permission like to
do
a big deal exorcism you know what I mean
but it's like if we don't have enough
evidence then they're gonna say no so
I'm gonna like come in here and do this
now Rick says to Stephanie he's like
what I want you to do is like I know you
guys have been doing like the ceiling
ritual like every night for a year or
whatever
he's like I want you guys to stop doing
that because
he's essentially in Chief and said this
like you're using me as bait and he's
like yeah pretty much it's we're just
gonna stop doing the prayer and see if
like some [__] up [__] happens because
we want to get the [__] up [__] on
tape so we can take it to the church and
say hey we need to do an exorcism on
this lady you know what I mean so that's
what they're trying to do
so the first night so they're there for
two nights and the first night they're
there and again he said like just [__]
all happened nothing happened like the
first night absolutely nothing
but the second night
um Stephanie is in the kitchen and she
gets scratched to get on her arm like
really deep like right on her forearm
and um nobody saw well they saw it on
tape like because they were watching you
know they had cameras all around like
monitoring so they saw it happen but
it's you know Rick was like I hate to
say this to her and it's like and she
got kind of offended but he's like you
know I didn't see it happen like on the
tape so it's like you could have faked
that you know what I mean like he's like
I'm not saying you did he's just saying
that you could have and it wouldn't good
be good enough for like for the church
is what they were trying to do they were
trying to get actual evidence like on
tape yeah
he sees her on the video has to have a
reaction but he didn't see the scrapes
and then she goes off camera and then I
think she sees then then she approaches
him
and then she's got the scratches and he
said she could have made the scratches
herself right away once she yeah because
he's like she was out of my sight right
so he's like you know and like I said
she was kind of offended but but she
understood like what he was talking
about he's like I'm not saying you did
do that he's just saying you could have
done that and it's like if I say that to
the church that's what they're gonna say
and it's like you know so it's not good
enough
so he said interestingly though he's
like the cuts were really deep he said
there was actually a pool of blood on
the floor and he's like there was also
some blood spatter like on the wall
like where she had been standing as
though it had been like like that yeah
you know what I mean so yeah like like I
said she could have done it sure but
it's like I don't know she didn't seem
like
I don't know I I guess she seemed fairly
credible
but you know you can't really tell it's
hard to tell most of the people on here
seem pretty credible because I guess if
they have like a real person on there
telling their story and they sound like
a loon then they don't put them on the
show right you know what I mean the the
only dude on here that sounded like a
loon was the dude that like had the had
the Egyptian god coming out he didn't
care that he sounded like and he said
and he was just trolling yeah he was
trolling I think yeah so it's like but
he I mean fair play to him he did keep a
straight face the whole time which I
would not have been able to so
um but yeah
so yeah so so Rick says okay well the
video evidence we did get it on video
but we didn't see it actually happen so
it's like it was significant but not
conclusive and so they have to like keep
at it
and then there's a thing where like the
camera goes fuzzy I don't know if that
really happened or if they just did that
for dramatic effect and then Rick
apparently sees scratches form on her
like while she's in the bedroom and he
saw it with his own eyes and I guess
they got it on camera too because they
were all excited about it I think it was
on her leg
wasn't it yeah I think it was like on
her leg that time but he's like I
actually saw it happen that time like I
saw it like open up in her leg and we
did get it on camera so they decide they
are going to take the [__] to the church
but the thing about it though is that
they didn't even end up that that whole
like plot sideline like that didn't even
really end up mattering because they
didn't even
I don't even know if they took the the
evidence to the church at all because
they just ended up they said oh well no
time to like go to the church and have
them [__] around and not and tell us we
can't do an exorcism we're gonna have to
like we gotta do this [__] right now so
yeah I don't know
so they bring in Good Old David
considine on the [__] who has been on
the show many times before uh I feel
like was was he was he um like
associated with the Warrens
I think he was I think that because I
think that was that priest right he's a
demonologist well he's like not here's
the thing that I'm not really sure how
all of this works he's not like an
official official demonologist yeah
because doesn't the Catholic Church have
some official demonologists even though
I think they say they don't but I think
they do
but I think he's kind of like a
freelance demonologist if that makes any
sense like I guess they'll call him in
on some [__] so he's kind of sanctioned
but he's not like official official
which I don't know if you have to have
like a license like a demonology license
the problem when they call in psychics
or demonologists is they're always going
to see this through the framework of
what they've been studying no matter
what you're going to call in a
demonologist and he's gonna go see it
and go oh by the way oh you know what
this isn't a demon this is just
telekinesis this is rspk he's never
gonna say that because they're gonna say
okay well then if it's that's not your
specialty then go off the case yeah get
out of here get a pair of psychology
he's like yeah I don't have a job yeah
unless I come in here and say
everything's demons yeah it's gonna oh
it's demons yeah it's you know just like
oh you got a bad one the Warrens were
demonologists so everything was a
[__] David of course yeah oh this
isn't rspk
from a kid or anything this is this is a
demon because they have to if not
they're out of the job
yeah and like I said yeah because if
they said oh it's not a demon that
everybody's like what the [__] are you
even here for like get out my house yeah
well all right they say rspks recurrent
spontaneous psychokinesis uncontrolled
on the subconscious of a kid uh but no
uh the Poltergeist is a demon well I
think what they would do too because I
know that they did this on a few other
cases was that they would come in and
they'd be like oh well you got like they
would even sometimes say oh maybe it's
Poltergeist or you have Spirits in here
but a demon is controlling it yeah like
you got a demon too Demon's bringing
this [__] in right yeah so it's like
Damon has a whole Army of paranormal
right everything's under the control of
the demon yeah so that's how they would
kind of like it'd be awesome if they
actually worked though yeah
I don't know I don't think it would be
awesome if like demons really existed
but they don't so it's okay
I was listening to Merciful Fate and the
lyrics are like that looking for their
first album dude says that he was raised
from the dead by spirits to become a
mercenary for Satan
man
that's a heavy [__] bro
yeah yeah I like [__] I was a
mercenary for Satan a mercenary for
Satan yeah sure and then he tastes
pretty good and then he's singing about
he's gonna kill this priest because she
he killed his girlfriend who was a witch
and now he's [__] getting revenge on
them all and her ghost is watching and
he's called her back from the dead
that's like straight out of hammer
horror that's some good [__] man that's
a good [__] that's probably why they got
the idea yeah
he could sing as like a man or a woman
or a child he could do whole operas and
play every part with his voice he's a
good vocalist I'd [__] we would try
to sing to [__] Merciful Fate albums
and you'd just play yourself you just
couldn't sing like that
and he's still good man I saw him live
live act live show on YouTube and
everything it's all hot you know a
[__] expensive show you know with a
bunch of [__] effects and everything
great stage everything looks like he's
singing from a satanic [__]
Pulpit you know what I mean like he's in
a [__] church and [__] with a crown
on or these crowns and [__] black and
white [__] makeup and everything it's
just a good show it's not hard by
today's standards about as hard as Iron
Maiden but his vocals are the [__]
they're the [__] I think it was from I
think it was Norwegian I think I can't
remember yeah something like that yeah
good man good man
yeah but it just kind of reminds me when
you when you talk when they talk about
this [__] it brings you back to me being
a kid listening to Heaven
that's the [__] thinking of a heavy
metal album you got a demon and it's got
Poltergeist and it's got a whole Army of
things from Satan it's like out of Venom
album it's like off of venom you know I
used to like Venom too great great band
and I used to kind of take it seriously
because I had seen a poltergeist already
by this time
but then I realized as I got a little
bit older I was like oh basically what
I'm doing is I'm watching a movie yeah
they're just rolling to horror movies
yeah it's just been yeah this is
basically the Evil Dead a record
yeah yeah yeah I thought they maybe had
some hidden knowledge or something you
know I mean they knew about it now
they're just pulling their [__] straight
out of their asses instead of hammer
horror movies yeah like I said they just
are real into horror movies they're like
let's let's write a song about that yeah
yeah witches and Satan and Satan and
[__] werewolves and and what was
happening in having a war in in heaven
the demons are trying to take over
having to kick all the Angels out so
they can have it
that's a wild [__] they got gold toilets
and everything gold toilets trying to
kick God out of heaven so they could
take over
murder Hornet says those Ghost Hunter
shows they scratch themselves yeah I bet
they do yeah like they just turn around
it's like oh [__] look at that oh my
oh my just like that [__] they do it's
like did you hear that no we didn't hear
anything stop yeah
Samantha said just saw the Warrens uh
Sil which I guess is sister-in-law
saying they're having a paranormal con
up in Connecticut on October 27th 28th
Annabelle will be there oh they're
bringing Annabelle the doll are they
gonna keep her in the glass case because
you know what happens if you let her out
of the glass case everyone's gonna get
possessed and that's not gonna be a good
time for anybody it's lost and it's all
around if any of y'all are new to the
show
we love the haunting series not all the
cases are real credible they're fun
though
and uh we'll bag on
paranormal tropes but I don't bag on the
Paranormal I've seen paranormal stuff
it's real it's just that it doesn't come
across in these it's very rare and it
doesn't come across in these episodes
It's
they're very highly fictionalized and a
lot of this is is fake
the real [__] is like Poltergeist the
bet the best case there's the best
documented is this house is haunted
written by
guy lion play fair about the Enfield
Poltergeist up in England
all right that one was exactly like what
happened to me and my aunt my uncle it
just didn't last as long it only lasted
like two weeks
and it was recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis and it happens every now
and then and it's happened recently in
in this house but it only lasts like a
couple episodes a couple things might
happen in a day and then to go like six
months or maybe in a year nothing will
happen and then it'll happen again and
it's always when I'm under a lot of
stress or
or I think about it too much
but it's just little parlor tricks that
you can't gain anything off of them you
know they
you something will move or be thrown and
you're like man or somebody might
teleport you're like where'd that how'd
that get here like
uh like one time it says why doesn't it
do anything useful why doesn't bring me
a [__] a whole bunch of money
and it did a few seconds later the stack
of coins from you're like gee thanks
from my dresser which was already yours
I was like that's not what I was
thinking big palette of a hundred
percent send me that but
unmarked bills please yeah but it's
limited in what it does what it could do
I guess so or or it's just being a
jackal or it's being a dick yeah or it
doesn't do things that you wouldn't do
you know you think well Stephen's
immoral so I'm not going to steal I'm
just going to take my own money and give
it to me
it might be something like that I don't
think stealing from my back is immoral
so they can say so that's what I mean so
Poltergeist can just give me money I
don't have a problem with it yeah but
you've got more but I'm scared of it if
it gets ramped up we've talked about it
earlier on the I'm afraid that it might
kill somebody
um like me no you might might try to
kill me
even though it's generated from me you
know uh just there's just there's no
Talent what it could do
yeah you got all kind of crazy [__]
going on in there yeah it's a second
yeah
it might be that thing like out of the
damn Venom you know I made you and all
that kind of [__] you know you you
failed me and it kills me yeah I don't
know something might be something like
that different facets Tom relates to
them really yeah like like that like I
said that and the scene the scene and
The Shining where Jack Nicholson's going
down the hall going yeah like down the
[__] there's a Gold Room Tom's like
yeah I feel that
yeah my version of Venom in there is not
it's kind of like Venom but it's also
kind of like a green goblet
the the William Dafoe Green Goblet
that's what its voice is like
yeah yeah mine's not that bad yeah I
think everybody has that yeah the inner
fast it's talking to you things right
and stuff because they made a whole
animated movie about that you know like
about all the little people like what
the [__] was the name of that thing
inside out or something like that it was
just like a bunch of little people like
living in their head like fighting all
the time yeah well some of those things
in your deep
Consciousness and your unconscious
kind of like something out of them
um who's that guy who wrote the uh the
[__]
it's like a jungian [__] forces some
of that stuff
some of those have the ability to have
psychokinesis
your conscious mind doesn't seem to have
that ability but some of your
unconscious mind some of your
unconscious personalities can do that
they can act under the suggestion of
your of your conscious and mind but not
directly
and some of those things in there are
bad so
are kind of bad
yeah you never know yeah you never know
what's gonna happen
so all right where did where did we go
astray oh okay so yeah we're talking
about David considine yeah so who like I
said has been on several and I'm pretty
sure he's associated with the Warrens
because and I think he's been on summer
because like I said he's like a
freelance demonologist I don't know what
they call it but he's not like sanction
sanctioned but they will call him in on
stuff
so here's what they decide to do and I
thought this was kind of interesting and
I don't really
uh I mean I get what the what the uh
theory behind this was but I don't think
I've ever seen them like talk about this
so he said they're gonna do a mass in
Stephanie's name
but they're not gonna tell her that
they're doing that now they said that
she's not possessed she's just under
demonic oppression which I guess is just
like the step before that's when the
demon is just like sitting on your head
yeah rather than just like yeah before
he like goes up in your booty or whoever
it is that demons get into your body but
yeah through your booty I mean they come
out of your booty too
I mean I figured they would probably go
in your booty yeah
but yeah so right now it hasn't gone on
everybody it's just like sitting on her
head so so she's demonically oppressed
so they're like okay
so what they did was they had a priest
who was like not associated with
anything the priest was in Chicago
and remember I said this is man asses
Virginia Manassas I know but I like to
call it man asses
um so so it's however many miles that is
um it's a lot
and so they have this priest in Chicago
doing the mass for her but they didn't
tell her that they were doing it and so
like they had to act all I guess they
wanted to see if she would
react to it like because they knew it
was going on but she didn't that's the
story that they told anyway
so Rick goes over to Stephanie's house
and he's acting like all [__] casual
and [__] like that hey what's up just
thought I'd stop by and see you but
really he was like just looking at her
to see if she was gonna react because he
knew that the mass was going on like in
a city far away
now in Chicago where the priest is doing
this [__] and like I said I'm sure this
is probably like artistic license that
they were taking because I don't know if
they knew anything I don't even know if
they said the priest's name
but he had the whole thing like wind was
blowing his hair and the candles were
blowing out and all that kind of crap uh
in man asses man
um
she likes she likes jock straps and she
[__] has fantasies of peg in a
[__]
happens yet
put your ankles behind your ears
[Laughter]
sitting over there where the goddamn
fire hydrant in her head you're no fun
you're no fun yeah man it's all funny
games it is yeah
I wouldn't do it against your will
see look at that that's how I'm just
gonna talk you into it
someday
someday you'll be really really drunk
I'm just [__] with you I wouldn't do
that
yeah you would not unless you said I
could
[__] naughty ass [__] nevertheless
yeah so uh so yeah
so she's in Virginia and she said that
she um felt as though someone set a bomb
off in her head because she was like I
don't feel too good like what the [__]
is going on and [__] like that and then
Rick's like because he knew that there
was like a mask going on like way far
away like in Chicago and he's just like
oh see she knows what's going on
um and then what the [__] is that word
I don't even know what that word is like
I've I'm writing the notes down really
fast and I'm just like
um it's not messy it's just I can't
figure out what that word was supposed
to be
but yeah she was like she's like she
started feeling really dizzy she got
like a horrible migraine and at this
point they said okay well now she's in
danger of being like fully possessed
like I said like you know the demon
might be going up in her booty instead
of just sitting on her head like I said
so at this point Rick calls up David
considine who I guess has just been
sitting on the sidelines this whole time
and they're just like okay well we don't
have time for you know for the Catholic
Church to get off their fat asses and
like say that we can do exorcism because
they have to give permission to it it's
like that's so silly to me I was like
just do it it's not like they're gonna
find out you know what I mean you're
just going in someone's house like
saying a bunch of [__] and throwing like
holy water around it's not like anyone's
gonna nark on you I don't know but so
they just go in there they're like well
we could do a minor right of exorcism
you can't do like the full on
deal like without the church's
permission but I guess you can just do
like the little lame ass trial version
like of the exorcism so they decide
they're gonna do that because that's
like all they can do and they don't have
time to sit around waiting for the
Catholic Church to give them permission
so Rick decides he's gonna do it and so
he has to do like a spiritual cleansing
of his own self
um you know he has to go to confession
and all that jazz
um and then he's gonna go you know kick
some Demon ass apparently
so at this point like I said this is
what I'm talking about about the later
seasons of the show like patting [__]
out because he's like he comes in with
the book or whatever and he's like I'm
gonna read the whole ritual
and then Stephanie and Nick have to
repeat everything and they did they read
the whole thing and then like they
repeated it I'm like really are we
really gonna read this whole thing right
now like this is taking like 10 [__]
minutes yeah it's I mean maybe it wasn't
10 minutes but it seemed like it took a
while because I was like yeah they were
really like patting out the runtime
they're really bad not the wrong time
because I was like yeah we get the gist
okay yeah one thing about
The Haunting you know in this particular
season this is season six right six
seven
yeah they are fun to watch they are like
little yeah we always have a good time
watching them they're like something out
of The Conjuring Universe it's like our
Sunday night ritual you know what I mean
like after we do the the movie live
stream like we come in and get cleaned
up and get in bed with snacks and like
watch the [__] yeah they're like
little horror movies yeah
um
there's not a lot of substance to them
to help you know to help you kind of
like uh make some kind of long distance
analysis of the case you just gotta take
it at its word there's not enough detail
there
yeah I mean honestly we talk about it
you know and we kind of like debate the
finer points of like how how realistic
or how you know we think this is but I
just kind of approach them as though
they're horror movies yeah you know what
I mean now there'll be Witnesses but
they're always a witness involved with
the case there's never anybody from the
outside that's kind of like watching the
investigation and you know going like
did that really happen you know there
isn't like a
like a uh I don't want to say a skeptic
but like a an impartial witness right
there isn't
because sometimes a skeptic is a
professional skeptic they'll [__]
deny they saw something when they did
you know what I mean I mean that there's
that possibility but you need somebody
who's impartial
to to the case
and they never have that all these never
it's always somebody who is partial to
the case yeah I mean because I guess the
point of the show is just to entertain
people and creep them out yeah and so
they're just giving these people a
platform for like describing their
experiences or you know experiences that
they think they experienced or that they
just made up yeah and it would kind of
ruin the show if somebody's showed up
because oh yeah them nah they're full of
[__] they're always [__] making up
[__] you know then that's what I mean
see if you had like if you had some
[__] like me coming in there and
being like I don't think that happened
the way yeah
funny is that shit's always happening
when I wasn't there you know what I mean
[__] whenever I was there it was
quiet you know [__] so you don't know
yeah dude so see that's what like kills
me about that kind of said it's always
like very convenient yeah you know
but the same could be said kind of for
what happened to me and Mike and in our
case
uh no one else was around so I
understand although you said that that
um some people would Lois and Red's
neighbors their neighbors saw it yeah
but they had to have stayed there a
while right and they did see if they
were like wow you know it impressed him
it scared one dude his name was Jimmy he
saw this [__]
and he goes okay man I said I I gotta go
and they never saw him again he knocked
the [__] up
yeah he was scared
I can't remember exactly what he saw
was it the knife that got thrown they
they remembered they were older than me
when it happened
or was it
uh
I know that the little Matchbox cars got
rearranged right when they were right
next to him right and I said look that
that those are different now and he
looked down because ah you guys are full
of [__]
yeah but they were different and then
something else happened right after that
another 10 minutes later and he goes and
he saw that and he's like I gotta go I
gotta get out of here yeah he's like
you're shatana yeah yeah
I don't know if he thought it was
haunted he just scared him things were
moving
well yeah that would kind of weird you
out yeah
so uh so yeah so they basically read the
whole entire ritual it seemed like it
took forever
and you know with him saying the line
and them repeating it and bloody blah
then you have all your standard exorcism
tropes like you see in the show it's
like everybody's all windy everybody's
like yelling louder and louder lights
are flashing like [__] like that candles
for Flicker and whatnot
and then uh everything lights up outside
and I was like oh there it is smell of
sanctity yeah they never say that but
you know what I mean it was just like it
looked like it got daylight outside even
though it had been nighttime yeah and um
then after that everything was
apparently okay again like yeah you know
that was that was pretty much the end
like everything's okay now they still
said they didn't really know what caused
it although the you know the large
implication was that it was that [__]
douchebag that like cursed her
apparently and like did the love spell
and um she's like and we still don't
know anything about like you know the
the murderer that supposedly happened
here like the fam the guy that murdered
his whole family because she said she
only saw that ghost boy once and so like
she didn't really figure
what the hell was going on with that so
we don't know if it's like a demon and
ghosts or if it's just like one demon
who's pretending to be a little boy
ghost we don't know what's going on we
don't I know one thing though
I've been slacking I never did try to
find Donnie Decker the rain man that's
right
he's out of jail
by now
if any of you all could find Donnie
Decker the rain man give me drop drop it
drop us a [__] line
on Facebook or Instagram I want him on
as a guest I want to talk to Donnie
who's another Poltergeist kid you can
make it rain in his prison cell he made
it rain inside his house and from the
police okay
just rain out of nowhere and I'm [__]
that's what he did thought he was under
the attack by his grandfather who was
dead who who had heard him that's what
he said
so uh
he went to jail for arson again he went
back into jail he's got a lot of
problems but I've 100 believe his story
and there was a lot of impartial
Witnesses prison guards and wardens and
stuff they were scared of him
yeah he had some kind of some form of
psychokinesis where he could condense
water out of thin air and make rain
indoors
and the [__] they said some of the
raindrops to go sideways they can see
water crawling up the wall
man I totally believe it there's enough
witnesses that were
you know prison guards and [__]
that's the kind of stuff you know that
that a poltergeist phenomena Poltergeist
energy can do
um
spontaneous psychokinesis
that's [__] Sith Lord level [__] man
that's like the [__] [__] Vader was
doing while he's fighting [__]
throwing objects at people and [__]
I would have loved to have seen that I
believe him I want to have him on a show
well I always thought his case was kind
of interesting because especially like
you said where some of the people
reported seeing like uh the water like
flowing upwards of the wall and [__]
like that yeah because
Steve Mara who I wrote a couple books
with like about some of his cases he's
parapsychologist he's British and he did
a case in Rochdale
in England where the same thing happened
where like it would rain in their house
and he said the same thing that it's
like sometimes you would see the
raindrops going sideways or or up yeah
and so and he thought that was like
really interesting too but he was like
yeah it was like [__] pouring down
raining like in in their kitchen and
[__] yeah kind of like something out of
that old [__] anime cartoon Akira
where they had genetically engineered
that dude and he had that ability and he
could
do weird [__] like that
I want to see that one again I haven't
seen a care in a long time maybe we
should probably review that I haven't
yeah in a long time either I think he
eventually got to I think I think he
eventually got he could just kill
someone by thinking about it I think it
might be on HBO math
in their own kind of like something out
of scanners
that was a good movie too I would be in
I would be in big trouble if I had
scanners Powers I'd be blowing people's
heads up all the time yeah so it's
probably a good thing that I can't do
that because I'd be like yep you pissed
me off today plan I'm popping on yeah
business members in yeah saw that
episode yeah I think he was on well he
was on a couple shows I think he was on
did they did um they didn't do a
haunting about him but I think he was on
Paranormal Witness Paranormal Witness
and but he was on another show too was
it Unsolved Mysteries or yeah he was on
several of them some of us something
happened
and um
was going to have him on and it turned
out that he uh went back to prison
prison yeah uh his boss hired him he
worked at some kind of a bar and or a
restaurant and his boss hired him to
burn the place down so the boss could
get the insurance right and so he got
caught up in a in a
insurance fraud thing he had to do a few
years but that would have been over now
he'd be out by now yeah because that was
a long time yeah it was a long time ago
because I think when I when I wrote the
book uh when I wrote unseen hand and I
think I put his case in there and that
was several years ago and I think I
think he was in prison then but he was
due to get out it makes you wonder if he
could make it rain did he make it rain
when he went back to prison
I don't know it only happened when he
was real depressed
rain would start
that's crazy with me it happens when I'm
real frustrated
frustrated and angry yeah but it's just
things being thrown and things being
ripped off walls
yeah any kind of like extreme emotion
yeah is gonna trigger it off yeah or
like I said it did start happening when
we were just talking about it all the
time too because we were working on the
bus yeah it's more mellow if I'm just
talking about it's an object will appear
like how'd that get there right you know
and I saw a few things happened like I
looked at a ring and I looked away the
Ring went flying and it fluttered down
like a feather
not a metal ring but it flooded down
like a feather another one I saw a
little plastic shot glass as I was
playing a video game fall through about
three or four shelves inside of a little
bookcase type thing I have in it hit the
bottom went and then it vibrate
on its base for a few seconds and I
looked at it and it stopped
and the when that was happening the the
shades went up like they were blowing in
the wind but there was no wind in there
all the doors and windows were shut
but I was [__] into the video game it
didn't even [__] phase me I was just
like after it happened I was like
that was weird that's not supposed to
have it seemed totally natural when it
was going on yeah because like when it
threw the remote in front of the guys
and the guests and everything I wasn't
even phased it was like it was normal
yeah you weren't weirded out it was
weird but it's like I wasn't really
weirded out either like Dimitri and Jen
were kind of weirded out but they uh I
think they just thought it was neat yeah
he asked me because Tom do it again
I'm not gonna feel it but feel the hair
I had hair back let me feel the hair
standing up on the back of my neck like
it was coming back and I had to fight it
back down yeah like that I was afraid of
it yeah
yeah it's like let's let's not go down
that road we don't know what might
happen started to rev back up again
said every young frustrated man I've
ever known has a few holes punched in
walls yeah that's true
but he doesn't have to punch him you
don't have to punch it it just kind of
happens
that one of the last things that
did damage is it just ripped the [__]
molding off the [__]
the top of the cabinets
in our old house we had like um
there was like a molding or like a shelf
like on top of the kitchen cabinets
where you could put stuff yeah I had to
tour them molding I had a whole bunch of
wooden horses up there little
decorations they were about that tall
and it threw three of them off of there
simultaneously and it pulled the molding
off and they all hit the ground
simultaneously in one big crash it
happened all at once
yeah yeah well my back was turned as
soon as I turned away when I jumped and
looked and it's all laying there on the
ground
yeah and the um the molding was like
wrenched out or the nails were like
wrenched out yeah the nails were all
bent out it just did it instantly
yeah that was the most dramatic thing
that recently yeah when I was kidding
that was a couple of years ago yeah I
did that but when I was a kid it was
even better it was teleport but you were
like really mad that day yeah as I think
what the problem yeah
anger
yeah it's mad at my mom oh that's right
yeah that's right
yeah you just displaced rank just like
Pookie does when you tell her she can't
do something if you tell her she can't
do something then she immediately runs
over and just starts pulling the carpet
up oh yeah like that
anger displacement same kind of thing
all right so I guess that was the end of
that episode yeah so what did you think
about that episode Tom
it was it's kind of samey by the Time
season six comes around a lot of the
episodes are very similar maybe that's
why they started going in like weird
directions with like Egyptian yeah
crocodile Gods they're not bad they're
entertaining it's just that they start
to kind of blur together
um and the quality of the production is
pretty good the uh the incidental music
and everything and the scores are good
in them the acting is pretty good and
the special effects are very good for a
television series they did get a lot
better as like they went on yeah it's
just that you know that there's a lot of
show biz happening so it doesn't have
that kind of dry documentary feel of the
first couple seasons
yes we did and they kind of got a little
crazy sometimes but
but that's it comes are creepier to me
if it's more low-key yeah maybe that
doesn't make any sense to people but
it's like the second you start going
over the top and stuff it's like not
scary anymore yeah you know what I mean
because it seems less realistic yeah
but it's like you know if people are
just kind of like talking about
just kind of low-key [__] that they saw
like that's scarier to me yeah and I
think I've said that before too like
even in horror movies I'm usually
creeped out by [__] that is not like you
know just demons like popping out in
your face and stuff that's not scary but
it's like stuff that's like just
contextless and kind of like
um like there's really no reasoning
behind it or but it's just kind of
subtle but it's just kind of like weird
is like way creepier to me than like
something that's really overt if that
makes any sense yeah
no that makes a lot of sense yeah
because I've seen the real thing before
and it's usually not like I just said
you know it'll rip [__] off but that's
not rip [__] off of [__] molding off
the cabins and [__]
when that happens that's not as freaky
what's freaky is the more subtle [__]
that's like mysterious like it makes it
takes a bunch of hand towels and makes a
smiley face out of three see that's
creepy and you're going what the [__]
why did it do that that's creepy yeah it
made a smiley face
yeah I got a photograph of that that's
in the book
it laid a little hand towels out three
of them I got two eyes and a nose and a
mouth right or is it just two eyes in
the mouth
now I can't remember I gotta remember
what the photograph looks like but yeah
it's been a long time since yeah it's
just there on the bed
and we found that and I was just like
what the [__] does that mean
that's what I mean see that's scarier to
me because it's like why like yeah why
would it do that yeah
is it making fun of us is it watching us
is that an evil grin or is that a or is
it friendly Grid or is it being like hey
yeah so you can interpret it into a
bunch of different ways right what's
funny is that
when you walked into the room and it was
on the bed
it was upside down facing the other wall
so when it did it it was I guess looking
at it from the wall when it did it
not from where a person would be
standing in the room
that's kind of also see that's also kind
of creepy because you could almost kind
of like imagine like something like
coming out the wall I like doing it yeah
but like I said that's like scarier it
did it From Another Dimension so it
didn't matter which way it was standing
and it did it fast a few seconds and I
don't know where their towels came from
they were from the house but I don't
know how they got in there we were in
the hallway so they must have teleported
in there
they didn't they weren't in that room
so that was always the mysterious
[__] thing like yeah that object
appeared in there but it
how did it get in there it didn't pass
us we were in the hallway
so how did he get there did it go
through the wall physically or did it
just pop in there
like through it through a dimension door
never could catch it it was it was fast
it's always when you weren't looking at
it and I started to think well it can't
do it when you're looking at it because
you're reinforcing reality
when you look away from something it's
in a gray Zone where no one's looking so
it's it can manipulate an object's
location when you're not confirming it
like Schrodinger's cat you know what I
mean it was something like that
well that's something that's really
common in a lot of poltergeist cases
that I wrote about it's like very very
rarely do people see anything like the
start of the motion yeah you see the end
you know you'll see something flying and
like they see it when it's already in
motion like no one no one happens to be
looking at the Candlestick or whatever
it is like when it picks itself off off
the table right you just kind of see it
out of your peripheral vision when it's
already like yeah the closest I mean
that was backing away from a pin I told
her to write something down and reds
behind me and I'm walking out the door
and I'm looking at the pin and I was
expecting to see the pin jump up I was
kind of treading it but I was like I was
afraid to see it but I thought I might
do it I thought the pin might jump up
and start scribbling
you know on that page yeah that pad and
as I was backing away from it going out
the door was looking at the pin the next
thing I know I just saw a gleam of light
and the pin was [__] halfway across
the room zooming right at me like a
bullet it hit me right in the chest and
bounced off my chest I heard it it
sounded like a [__] pow because it
was like a big pen you know the inside
of that yeah I heard it snap noise it
hit me in the chest as I was shutting
the door and it was about only that much
weight and it went back out through the
door the second I shot it
and I looked back right and saw the
whole thing and stamina and I said did
you see that he goes yeah I said no that
didn't happen that didn't happen because
yeah it happened no no no no no no no no
no I [__] walked away it scared me
man it was about 14 I think yeah
something like that oh man
I couldn't believe that that happened
yeah it hit me and then bounced off my
forearm and then when it got sucked out
through that little two inch crack in
the door as I was shutting it
as fast like a bullet
and I didn't see it pick up off of the
table
it was already halfway across the
[__] room zooming towards me as fast
yeah but he wasn't going in an ark it
was going in a straight line like it was
shot
when the [__] happened at our old house
I didn't see the remote pick up off the
table I saw it when it was already in
the air yeah
because I was like because at first I
thought that I kicked the table and like
but then I was like no I didn't kick the
table like I didn't even touch the table
and when it hit it didn't sound normal
it was like boom right when it hit the
ground but I didn't see it actually
leave the tape I wasn't looking I mean I
was looking
right over it because I was like looking
at the TV or I was looking across the
room and it was like under my so I saw
it when it was like lift but I didn't
see it like actually lift off I just
happened it was just kind of already
flying
you know what I'm saying murder harness
says Tom has the force it's the dark
side of the force yeah yeah gotta watch
it like I said yeah
because I'm always like one of these
days he said one of these days he's
gonna get mad at me and like Wing a
brick at my head he doesn't seem to do
it like that though no it doesn't yeah
yeah it's usually it's got some kind of
rules with it I don't kind of understand
it
yeah you can't make it happen it just
does it
well you I think you said this I might
have put this in the book too but you
said you can't like make it you have to
like allow it yeah
and it's you can't do it from nothing it
takes a few weeks
of thinking about it to kind of
start getting it revved up and then once
the ball starts rolling it gets easier
and easier to do and it does more and
more impressive [__] to where to scare
you
and then you got to try to stop it it'll
go [__] Haywire so I was afraid it
would be go like
that girl from the fire starter or once
she got good at it she couldn't control
how hot it would get and then she just
started like turning everything out and
trying to [__] put the heat into the
damn tub and it turned into steam and
[__] and [__]
yeah so I'm always afraid it would get
out of control
yeah I mean yeah that is a valid concern
and it might turn on me too so I don't
know right might be self-hatred involved
I don't know yeah that would be bad yeah
well it's like Venom right the thing
that's doing it it's like Venom
it's not a good thing really but it can
soften it'll do funny [__] too so I'm
not sure
it might be more than one of them
you got all kind of entities in there a
little facets of your personality yeah
doing all kind of crazy yeah
yeah you got all you got multitudes in
there too yeah
hahaha four or five of them
they talk to each other
they're always like fighting themselves
it's like a council they're trying to
come to an agreement
how does that go usually they're
fighting yeah yeah it's usually when I'm
under a lot of stress and I start going
inward yeah if I'm relaxed and
everything's going normally you know
what I mean it takes a few weeks for it
to
get bad like that it doesn't happen
immediately
you got to get a situation where your
mental health starts to suffer or
something you know and it'll like builds
up it builds up yeah right
all right well
you ready to wrap some [__] out yeah
let's wrap it up because it's quarter to
nine I gotta start and I'm yeah I've
been up since 3 30. I'm like getting
really retired but uh yeah so hopefully
you guys enjoyed this live stream this
evening talking about marched by evil
not stalked by evil as I said we did
stalk by evil so you might want to go
watch that one too but uh yeah so we'll
be back on Wednesday night for the main
show and the thing that won this time
this was really interesting because I
didn't know a lot about this I think
somebody I don't remember who it was but
somebody recommended this topic like a
long time ago and I had put it in the
poll a couple times that never won but
it did win this time and that is the I
feel like in the United States we
probably don't know much about this but
it's a very very famous female Irish
pirate
named Grace O'Malley who was kind of
like a folk hero like in Ireland okay
um kind of a badass all right so uh you
know I've been reading a little bit
about her like over the last couple days
and stuff like that
so that's what we're gonna do the show
about uh Grace O'Malley that should be a
good show I think it's like gonna be
really interesting so I don't remember
like who recommended it because it was a
long time ago but you know good topic
and that's what we're going to be
talking about on Wednesday so hopefully
everybody can join us for that so have a
good rest of your evening you guys have
a good day tomorrow and we'll see you
again on Wednesday night good night